[Musique]
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est l'invité de
preuve par 3 bonsoir Jean-Luc Mélenchon
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de Public Sénat avec
l'Agence France Presse trois grandes
parties comme chaque semaine et trois
grandes questions auxquelles vous devrez
répondre première question est-ce que
vous appelez à l'explosion sociale alors
que François Hollande plaide pour le
dialogue comme seule façon dit-il de
sauver notre modèle social 2ème question
vous répondrez ne soyez pas si impatient
2ème question est-ce que vous serez
comptable des victoires du Front
national éventuel aux élections
régionales vous répondrez là à Lucile
Malandin de l'AFP alors que la désunion
de la gauche demeure après le référendum
organisé dimanche par le Parti
socialiste vous n'avez pas encore
commenter hein la réalisation de
Jean-Christophe cambadellis vous le
ferez dans un quart d'heure 3è question
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à propos de la Syrie
est-ce que vous faites confiance à
Vladimir Poutine pour nous débarrasser
du groupe état islamique est-ce lui donc
qui va nous débarrasser des djihadistes
vous le direz tout à l'heure à
perintarna de Public Sénat première
question donc on constate aujourd'hui
Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'économie le travail
semble engager dans une révolution celle
de de luubérisation
la fin du salariat et mais est-ce que
vous-même vous appelez les travailleurs
à la révolte dans notre pays mais c'est
pas rôle les travailleurs ils ont des
syndicats ils ont leurs propres moyen
d'expression et moi je me suis fait un
devoir constant de ne pas commenter les
stratégies des syndicats et de les
appuyer chaque fois que ils le veulent
ils le souhaitent le demandent alors
c'est vrai dans des entreprises dans des
cas particuliers je pense qu'il faut pas
folkloriser la question sociale elle
fait son retour sur la scène grâce aux
travailleurs d'airfance tout d'un coup
le pays et notamment la sphère
médiatique qui est totalement
imperméable à ce genre de pré occupation
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait une
situation sociale tendue avec des gens
qui sont dans le désespoir de perdre
leur travail de ne voir jamais leur
payug estce que vous encouragez
justement je le disais ah ben moi j'ai
toujours appelé bien sûr moi je je c'est
mon travail c'est votre travail c'est
mon travail de dire aux gens ne vous
résignez pas tenez tête défendez-vous
car si vous ne vous défendez pas et bien
on vous les moutons seront tondus voilà
ce que j'ai à dire je vais prendre un
exemple simple il y a tous les ans 535
un mort au travail pas à côté du travail
mais
53 par accident du travail il y en est
jamais question dans aucun média alors
que une voiture qui brûle fut-elle déjà
à moitié brûlée et cetera c'est tout de
suite un événement il y a donc une
espèce de
d'indifférence qui se traduit de bien
des Maur par exemple deux POS de mesure
au détriment des travailleursement
totalement et dans la la sphère publique
de ce qui se voit bien sûr regardez le
CSA lui-même qui n'est pour end pas un
héros de la lutte pour la liberté a été
obligé de constater dans son dernier
rapport que la catégorie sociale qui
apparaît le mois à l'écran ce sont les
ouvriers et employés qui sont pourtant
l'immense majorité de la population
active de ce pays il y a un mépris de
classe oui qui se voit de toutes les
manières possibles et qui a conduit
d'ailleurs certaines élites à se prendre
elles-même à leur propre propagande si
bien que quand a éclaté l'affaire Air
France essentiellement la bonne société
s'est préoccupée des très hauts cadres
qui avaient perdu leur chemise en
oubliant les 3000
personnes sont des salariés aussi par
ailleurs bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr mais
ils sont très bien défendus grâce à vous
et quelques autres euh mais par contre
la masse non la masse on va la ramasser
à 6h du matin euh euh sans sans qu'il y
ait aucune raison un abus de procédure
comme celui-là oui oui passons à autre
chose n'est-ce pas monsieur grossior
mais on ne passera pas autre chose il y
a un mépris de classe pour la classe
ouvrière pour les travailleurs pour les
salariés qui se manifestent tout le
temps donc est-ce que vous l'avez senti
je vous pose la question est que vous
savez monsieur grossur que deoravant les
gens mettent des chemises à moitié
déchirées dans les manif par exemple s
allent aux urgents des hôpitaux quand
ils sont en L il mettent des chemises
déchiré pour symboliser ce qui attend
ceux qui compent leur résist j'aimerais
vous interroger sur la dernière prise de
parole dans le domaine social de
François Holland je sais pas si vous
avez senti du mépris dans sa bouche pour
les travailleurs mais écoutez ce qu'il a
dit il a présenté l'enjeu en ces termes
c'était lundi donc à l'ouverture de
cette conférence sociale je rappelle qui
a été boycotté par la CGT le statut qu
n'est plus possible et l'alternative
c'est la réforme ou la
rupture la rénovation du modèle social
ou sa
disparition jamais les sujets de
négociation n'ont été aussi nombreux il
s'agit évidemment pas de toucher au
principe du Code du travail à la durée
légale du travail au SMIC au contrat de
travail alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce
qu'il d vrai seul les réformes pourront
demain sauver le modèle social
français'est- que vous répondezil dit
que le statut qu n'est pas possible oui
ah ben tout à fait le statut qu est
insupportable il faudrait limiter le la
possibilité d'accéder à du contrat à
durée déterminée pour les grandes
entreprises il faudrait limiter le
salaire des très haut patrons et ne pas
permettre qu'il y ait un écart plus
grand de que de 1 à 20 il faudrait que
le salaire des femmes soit celui des
hommes le statut CO est impossible mais
c'est pas de ça dont il parle il parle
d'aggraver la situation c'est-à-dire d'y
mettre ce qu'ils appellent dans leur
blabla la flexibilité je sais pas quoi
comment ils appellent ça mais bon le
président de la République comme
d'habitude prend les gens pour des
imbéciles il croi que depuis le temps
nous n'avons pas appris à lire les
chiffres que nous ne savons pas quelle
est la situation sociale réelle que nous
ne savons pas que pour que tous les
comptes sociaux soient ouverts il
faudrait faire comme on a fait sous le
gouvernement de Lionel Jospin injecter
de la capacité de consommation populaire
qui relance la machine économique du
pays bon bref il croit que nous ne
savons pas tout ça et que nous allons
impressionner je sais pas si vous
considérez que le chef de l'État nous
prend pour des imbéciles quand il cite
en exemple l'accord paritaire de la
semaine dernière pour sauver les R
complémentaire AC ce système de bonus
mal Clement il nous prend pour des
imbéciles d'abord il pratique un mépris
qui enrage les gens par exemple il dit
bon la CGT ne vient pas il il devrait
s'il veut vraiment se mêler de tout
puisqueapparemment le Monarque se mêle
de tout il pourrait s'interroger c'est
le premier syndicat du pays hein je je
le rappelle il a déploré il a déploré
l's il a dit c'est facile il y a les
autres qui signent à leur place voilà
est-ce que vous croyez que ce genre
d'attitude pousse au dialogue est-ce que
vous croyez que la CGT réellement ne
signe pas pour se défausser sur les
autres du soin de signé non la CGT
exprime un point de vue on est pour ou
on est contre on en est d'accord ou pas
mais on n pas le droit de les mépriser
d'un revers de main et en fait de les
traiter de menteur parce que c'est ce
qu'il fait et ensuite quand il cite
l'accord qui vient d'être conclu c'est
véritablement se moquer du monde c'est
de l'enfumage car avec ce système qui
d'abord n'est pas signé nous allons
maintenant interdire au cadrees en
particulier et à tous ceux qui ont une
retraite complémentaire de partir à
l'âge de la la retraite quand bien même
ils auraient payé le nombre d'annuités
et il y aura comme ils appellent ça une
décot c'està dire qu'il toucheront moins
jusqu'à l'âge alors on dit que c'est
pour sauver les comptes et que les
comptes sont pérenités mon gr le jour où
vous entendrez un chef d'entreprise de
ce niveau c'est-à-dire le le chef de
l'État qui est leur représentant du MDEF
ah pour vous c'est carrément le
représentant qu'est-ce que voulez que je
vous dise d'autres il applique leur
politique si s'il appliquit un début de
commencement d'une politique syndicale
vous pourriez dire ah ben comme
d'habitude le pouvoir de gauche aide ses
amis donc ben le pouvoir actuel aide ses
amis et c'est le MDEF bon donc il se
moque de nous bien évidemment il essae
de faire passer ça pour un bon accord
donc les gens qui m'écoutai vous avez
tous compris le dialogue social c'est on
vous amène une feuille vous signez vous
êtes licencié la réforme ça veut dire on
vous prend ce que vous avez voilà ce que
les mots sont devenus avec François
Hollande donc ça va à bon nous sommes
informés vous êtes encore plus opposant
de plus en plus opposants plus plus le
temps passe j'ai l'impression non mais
si non mais non c'est depuis le premier
jour je vous expliquais qui était cet
homme quelle était sa ligne et à
l'époque vous étie un certain nombre à
avoir cru ses discours parce que vous
n'aviez pas lu ce qu'il avait prononcé
auparavant et François Hollande a
toujours été sur cette ligne là toujours
donc c'est pas nouveau il a toujours eu
une pensée de droite à propos du social
et il l'applique aujourd'hui avec
méthode à propos justement des réformes
sociales évoqué par l'exécutif le chef
de l'État mais également manuel Vals on
le sait la prochaine étape c'est la
réforme du Code du travail est-ce que là
vous avez un inquiétude alors je je vous
vous dites que François hande c'est le
chef du MF on va éc le président du medf
pierre Gatas qui lui exprime ses
attentes on l'écoute le mod social
français a vécu nous sommes dans un
monde qui bouge encore une fois et donc
il faut adapter si vous voulez ce ce
modèle social aux grandes mutations il
faut en effet qu'on réforme la
législation du travail c'est le but du
rapport COMEL le code du travail la
législation du travail ce sont les
travaux du rapport comreuxel j'en
attends beaucoup ce que j'espère c'est
que ce gouvernement aura le courage
d'aller jusqu'au bout du rapport qu'
brexel pour en effet faire que l'accord
d'entreprise ou à défaut l'accord de
branche soit prioritaire sur le code du
travail qui devrait être réduit à une
cinquantaine d'articles clés voilà
pierre Gatas il veut un code du travail
de 50 pages et il compte sur le courage
dit-il du gouvernement bien sûr cette
extrême l'acheté serait pour à ses yeux
du courage mais je vais vous proposer
une autre chose Monsieur gataz Je vous
propose que dans chaque rue il y a un
code de la route différent pour tenir
compte des gens qui habitent le long de
la rue je vous propose que on ait une
gramères différentes suivant les gens
parce qu'après tout chacun veut bien
parler comme il veut tout ça est absurde
c'est prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles si l'accord d'entreprise est
plus fort que l'accord de branche et
l'accord de branche plus fort que la loi
ça veut dire qu'on renverse de fond en
comble toute la hiérarchie des norme EN
FRANCE et il dit ça avec sa petite mine
l'air content de lui comme s'il avait
fait une trouvaille en jouant le violon
traditionnel le monde change donc on
doit changer mais lui pourrait changer
par exemple il pourrait arrêter d'agiter
sa sébile tous les jours devant le
contribuable pour réclamer euh des
allègements de ceci des subventions à
cela c'est lui qui devrait changer c'est
lui qui devrait dire le pays va
tellement mal qu'on va un peu partager
c'est lui qui devrait dire au lieu de
garder des cadres et des cadres
intermédiaires au travail 1 an 2 ans de
plus pour qu'il n'it pas une décote nous
leur permettons de partir à la retraite
ce qui permet d'embaucher des jeunes les
jeunes pressent la place des prennent la
place des seniors et comme ils
commencent dans leur carrière écoute
moins cher l'entreprise il gagne non
mais ils sont tellement radins tellement
ratau qu'à l'idée de partager pour les
retraites compl aire et de mettre la
main à la poche il préfèr se couper les
doigts que de mettre les doigts sur leur
portefeuille pourquoi Monsieur grossior
trouvez-vous normal que ce bel accord
dont le président se régale soit payé à
90 % par les salariés et Le Rest
c'est-à-dire quelques millions par le
patronat accord paritaire c'est un
accord paritaire je le rappelle non mais
c'est un accord paritaire d'abord un il
est pas signé deuxièmement la décision
n'est pas paritaire puisque deux
syndicat et pas des moindres F et la CGT
son compte donc ça fait un drôle de
paritaire qu'est-ce qui est paritaire à
part la chaise et le fauteuil et la
table autour de laquelle on s'assoit je
vous en prie Monsieur grossior restons
sérieux dans cette affaire le le
patronat refuse de payer je parle
évidemment du grand patronat parce que
les autres on leur demande pas leur avis
car il y a aussi une chose qui est
extraordinaire monsieur grossior un vrai
sujet que représente le MDEF rien zéro
même pas ce que représente un syndicat
ouvrier vous savez pourquoi parce que
les syndicats ouvriers eux il passe aux
élections professionnelles tous les 4
ans le MDEF jamais grâce à l'UMP qui a
mis un amendement dans la loi ils ne
sont pas obligés de prouver leur
représentativité monsieur grossior la
dernière fois qu'on a voté pour le
collège patronal les chefs d'entreprise
du secteur de de l'entreprise sociale et
solidaire pesait 19 % des voix ces
gens-là on leur demande jamais leur avis
dans une négociation paritaire alors
vous voyez bien monsieur gataz est une
espèce de diplodocus qui arrive
directement du passé avec les pensées du
passé les méthodes du passé et une
mauvaise foi absolument aveuglante
puisque ce qui il dit et le contraire de
ce qu'il faudrait faire pour ce pays il
le sait très bien ça sert ses intérêts
ça ne sert pas l'intérêt général est-ce
qu'il faut redouter tant que cela un
toilettage du Code du travail vous avvez
trouvé la question provoquante peut-être
à partir du moment où François Hollande
dit on va pas toucher à trois verrou le
SMIC qui est la durée du travail et qui
est le contrat oui bien sûr mais je ne
le crois pas car monsieur Gatas n
demande pas qu'on toilette le code du
travail qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire vous voulez toiletter aussi la
nuè pendant que vous y êtes il y a trop
de pages donc a à supprimé des numéros
tout ça est grotesque euh on voit
régulièrement des guignoles euh venir
avec une pile de papier en regardez il y
a tout ça dedans mais vous avez qu'à
regarder la notice de votre machine à
laver hein elle aussi elle est épaisse
alors vous pourriez la toiletter on se
moque du monde tout le temps il y a pas
besoin de toileter le code du travail il
est en permanence les assemblées
travaillent dessus j'ai été
parlementaire assez longtemps pour le
savoir CZ alors euh je me souviens vous
avez été parlementaire très longtemps je
me'en souviens parfaitement vous le
savez jeanl des lois ass absolument
alors vous avez dit un jour il y a pas
très longtemps que France Hollande était
pire que Nicolas Sarkozy hein et
pourtant on a entendu François Hollande
c'était lundi matin dire qu'il était en
quelque sorte l'anti Sarkozi pourquoi
parce que lui respecte les corps
intermédiaires les fameux
syndicat et alors qu'est-ce que je suis
sensé une question une affirmation vous
contestez sa propre affirmation bah
évidemment ce ça je viens de le
démontrer je crois est-ce que c'est
respecté attendez monsieur grossior j'ai
dit qu'il était pire non pas à propos de
manère parler au gens il est égal à
lui-même c'estàd qu'il se manque de tout
le monde mais on parle du fond pourquoi
est-ce que je dis qu'il est pire pour me
poser cette question là sur quoi il est
pire c'est un peu le sens de ma question
par exemple le départ à la retraite il
est pire que Sarkozi parce que il vient
il dit aux gens je vous laisse partir à
à 60 ans et en réalité il sait que les
gens commencant à travailler à 23 pour
avoir 43 annuités ça veut dire qu'ils ne
pourront pas partir avant 66 à la
retraite peut-être qu'il est pas au
courant mais bien sûr que si qu'il est
au courant non il a fait les grandes
écoles il le sait qu'il ment il le sait
qu'il ment quand il dit ça au français
nésite pas à le faire quand alors et
quand vous est-ce que vous appelez une
marque de respect ou traiter avec
respect les corps intermédiaire de dire
de la CGT premier syndicat de ce pays il
ne signe pas mais c'est une sagré parce
qu'ils sont bien contents que les autres
c'est une marque de respect ça non c'est
pas une marque de respect vous avez
parlé du conflit Air France dans lequel
vous vous engagez donc qu'est-ce que
vous estimez là je vais encore citer
franis Hollande il dit qu'il la solution
passe par un effort de tous il parle de
la direction mais également des salariés
et des mais l'effort n'est pas de même
tout de mêmete non quel est le genre
d'effort vous voulez que les gens
fassent sur la productivité le nombre
d'Ur travailler vous connaissez la
problématique
concernant question non mais j'ai
compris que vous me posiez une question
vous inquiétez pas jeis pas trop vous
harceler mais je pourrais hein notez-le
bien mais alors qui alors dans ce pays
maintenant tout le monde monsieur le
Président de la République je sais pas
qui encore TR ou quatre de ces abagas
ont décidé tout d'un coup un matin en se
levant que on payait trop les pilotes
parce que c'est les pilotes après qu'ils
en on on nous sort et puis on dit on les
payz trop ah bon vous découvrez ça
maintenant et alors on va leur demander
de faire des heures de plus parce que en
plus ils sont médecins du travail
Monsieur Hollande et les autres abania
donc ils savent que ces gens-là se
reposent trop ils peuvent se reposer
moins tout c'est de la foutaise et le on
sort la figure du pilote maudit pourquoi
faire d'abord pour taper les cadres
supérieurs qui feraient bien dans ce
pays de se rendre compte que ce pouvoir
est leur ennemi au moins autant que la
droite et deuxièmement pour quoi faire
pour au nom des cadres taper les petits
qui sont au fr qui sont ailleurs qui
transportent des ceci des cela ont fait
beaucoup de sacrifice déjà d' voil on on
fait beaucoup on les a beaucoup humilié
et en plus on les embastillle le matin
vous avez remarqué qu'il y avait que des
gars de la base qui ont été pris à 6h du
matin hein été chercher un cadre on
écoute sur les violence récente Air
France justement les propos de Julien
dreay c'était dimanche sur Canal Plus et
il réagissait à votre proposition
d'aller en prison à la place d'autre
éventuellement et vous allez répondre
c'est facile de dire sur un plateau de
télévision qu'on va aller en prison à la
place d'autant qu'on sait qu'on nira pas
donc ça c'est facile c'est une posture
qui fait c'est une posture qui fait que
vous applaudissez tous en disant quel
courage quel formidable courage mais le
vrai courage le vrai courage c'est
d'aller affronter la direction de
négocier pied à pied de pas se laisser
faire et pas tomber dans la violence
parce que la direction à ce moment-là
vous l'avez vu elle se sert de la
violence pour renvoyer les salariés
devant leur difficultés alors qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à cela la notion du
courage là manifestement aussi à gauche
he rien je ne réponds rienéien parce que
ça pas d'intérêt quoi bon tout le monde
a compris ce que je voulais dire dans ce
pays j'ai exprimé ce qui était autrefois
la tâche d'un d'un homme de gauche je
continue à être de gauche bon Julien
Dren n'est plus il fait autre chose plus
ohcout lui non plus ça va quoi bon
est-ce que vraiment il a personne la
mieux qualifié pour parler du risque
d'aller en prison dans ce pays allons
allons allons bon donc prenons les
choses comme elles sont il a fait son
numéro il est devenu le le garde churme
en chef de la direction du parti tout
lui va bien il est content il a eu un
siège dans le Val De Mar mais son propos
est indit moi je l'ai connu comme un
révolté je l'ai connu à l'époque où il
fondit SOS Racisme je l'ai connu à
l'époque où ça c'était Julien Dray pas
cette chose que nous voyons là qui
défend l'ordre établi et se moque de qui
vous avez entendu ce qu'il a dit parce
que là vous avez choisi votre extrait
mais le moment où dit ouais ouais ouais
c'est le moment où il dit et bien si
jamais les gens continuent alors en face
on va se on va se donner des moyens on
va se durcir c'est bien ce que je dis il
a changé de camp il a changé
de mais moi je suis pas obligé de
commenter les retourneurs de vest de de
cette maison parce que je vais devenir
ça va me décoiffer toutes ces girouettes
hein alors une dernière question si
demain vous croisez François Hollande
est-ce que vous allez lui serrer la main
ou pas comme ce syndicaliste des
chantiers naval STX de saint-nazer oui
ou non moi je lui serraai la main parce
que je le connais depuis longtemps et le
syndicaliste de de saint-nazer c'est pas
une attitude personnelle qu'il a affirmé
c'est une attitude syndicale et
politique ses camarades avaient été
arrêtés la veille à 6h du matin il a
manifesté sa réprobation et son
indignation en tant qu'homme et il a a
refusé ce geste normal que qu'un homme
une personne qui a une autre attendez il
lui a refusé un geste normal parce que
le Président de la République lui a
refusé l'attitude normale qui été celle
du chef de l'État qui aurait consisté à
dire arrêter des gens à 6h du matin
alors qu'on aurait pu les convoquer et
qu'un ministre de mon gouvernement
monsieur Cahusac lui n'a pas été
interpellé à 6h du matin et bien je
comprends que vous soyez indigné mais
comme le chef de l'État n'a pas eu n'a
pas su avoir cette parole humaine
fraternelle à l'égard des travailleurs
et bien lui rendre et ils ont raison et
ceux qui ne lui serent pas la main je ne
leur jette pas la pierre très bien mais
en tous les cas vous vous continuerez à
lui serrer la main quand vous le
croiserez mais sinon vous seriez là tous
après moi pourquoi vous lui serrez pas
la main et cetera je vous dir vous
disent bon voilà je le croise il me
sourit il me tend la main je vais la lui
tendre mais ça voudra pas dire pour
autant que j'ai envie de l'embrasser
croyez-mo ça on l'a bien compris je
crois après tous les mots que vous avez
utilisé pour le qualifierin deuxème
partie de PR 3 Jean-Luc Mélenchon Lucile
Malandin de la FP donc va vous poser
cette question est-ce que vous serait
comptable des victoires éventuelles du
Front national s'il en remporte
évidemment aux élections régionales oui
oui oui oui c'est elle qui va arriver
puisque les sondages la question porte
bien sûr sur les régionales avec ces
sondages qui donnent vous l'avez vu
Marine Le Pen et Marion maréchal Le Pen
en première
placee ça pas faire peur ou quand même
ça vous fait pas peur ah vous allez nous
dire si ça vous fait peur en tous les
cas l'appel à l'unité à gauche est passé
au PS par le référendum de dimanche
organisé par Jean-Christophe cambadellis
c'est le top pas le
flop c'est un Paris
gagné
l'unité a de la dynamique ceci est
visible tout à la fois sur le terrain
mais aussi dans les sondages qui ont été
organisés sur le terrain de l'unité on
le voit dans tous les électorats et la
division est en
recul voilà Lucile Malandin est donc là
maintenant pour vous poser cette
question ch euh alors vous venez
d'entendre Jean-Christophe cambadéiss
qui espère faire bouger les lignes à
gauche
euh sinon s'il n'y arrive pas est-ce que
vous serez comptable des victoires du FN
éventuel là au régional commençons par
dire une chose qui me paraît assez
évidente les responsables d'un résultat
électoral ce sont les électeurs d'accord
don les électeurs les électeurs sont pas
des marionnettes dont nous disposons
dans nos bureaux avec des boutons où
nous appuierons toi votes pour c toi
votre pour là donc nous parlons de qui
les électeurs le peuple français donc
qui est responsable du résultat des
élections le peuple français quel est
l'enjeu dans une société démocratique
les partis doivent convaincre ou les
organisations ou les candidats donc si
le Front national l'emporte c'est que
nous ne sommes pas en état de convaincre
donc posons-nous la question de
savoirofre également posons-nous la
question de savoir pourquoi n nous nous
je dis nous je suis bien gentil he est
le nous ne convaincons pas bien sûr et
c'est là que le problème se pose vous
venez d'en avoir la démonstration euh
Jean-Christophe cambadellis dit alors
voilà ou bien c'est l'union ou bien
c'est la division et au savoir à peu
près l'équivalent de dire où c'est le
jour ou c'est la nuit il a fait cette
découverte ou bien c'est l'union ou bien
c'est la division il se demande pas
pourquoi c'est la division il nous
ordonne d'obtempérer et de venir faire
de la figuration sur les listes
socialistes mais si les gens se
détournent des partis socialistes UMP et
compagnie pourquoi c'est bien il y a
bien une raison pourquoi irons-nous
épouser ca même que les gens rejettent
c'est absurde donc si Jean-Christophe
cambadelli s' avait dit écoutez quelles
sont vos conditions pour faire l'union
s'il m'avait demandé quel est le quel
est le le tarif d'entrée pour c'est ce
qu'il a probablement demandé un certain
nombre de verres et un et dans certains
cas au parti communistes non mais je
sais pas ce je ne crois pas les
communistes ne m'ont pas accepté quoi
madame de de figurer aussi sur des
listes PS dans dans certaines régions
dans quelle région je pense à la
Bretagne non non non non ça ne se fera
pas non non non mais qu'est-ce que vous
racontez la Bretagne non non non non non
non non non écoutez-moi je sais pas ce
qu'il a dit aux uns et aux autres je
sais ce que je peux répondre moi
d'accord moi je ne parle pas d'abord je
je n'accepte pas qu'on me prenne pour un
igo il a créé lui-même 13 régions qui
n'existaient pas avant aucune structure
de parti ne correspond à ça aucune
structure de l'État il a fait ça après
avoir démantelé le sens des conseils
généraux appelé dorénavant assemblée
départemental donc cet homme a fracassé
la démocratie les cadres traditionnels
de la démocratie dans notre pays donc
venez pas me raconter qu'il y a 13
élections régionales ce n'est pas vrai
quand on habite Gueret on est dans la
même région que Biaritz c'est de
l'enfumage de foutage de gueule point
barre et ceux qui disent autre chose
sont des menteurs donc malgré ça il y a
ces élections d'accord si on m'avait dit
il y a un risque d'abord le risque ça
commence à bien faire vous savez vous
savez le risque il est là hein mais mais
je comprends pas mais Madame Le Pen et
le Front national ce n'est pas un parti
interdit non sauf erreur alors c'est
quoi votre faire mais est-ce que la
gauche va pouvoir se maintenir
systématiquement au deième tour alors
mais ça nous n'y sommes pas au deième
tour nous allons voir si ce d'abord qui
arrive en tête parce que il y a quelque
chose que vous avez l'air d'ignorer
c'est que les socialistes quand ils ne
sont pas en tête ils ne se désistent pas
à Grenoble au deuxème tour les
socialistes ne se sont pas désistés
alors que nous étions en test alors de
quoi on parle qui est responsable de
quoi le Front National est un parti
pardon pourquoi ne se sont-ils pas
désistés je les comprends parce que nous
avions dit c'est ligne qu'on appliquera
pas la vôtre parce que c'est nous qui
sommes en tête alors ils ont dit nous
restons sur notre ligne de droite et
nous voulons continuer contre vous pour
vous empêcher de gagner il préférait
faire gagner la droite que de faire
gagner la gauche à
grenob du Parti socialiste est
comparable à une liste du Front national
mais pourquoi voulez-vous me poser des
me faire dire des choses absurdes bien
sûr que non c'est pas la même chose mais
de quel droit au non du fait que ça
n'est pas la même chose ils vont avoir
le droit de venir à me mettre le
revolver sur la temple et me dire vote
pour nous des fistes et viens vite avec
nous de peur du Front national si on
fait ça le Front national sera sans
doute plus puissant pourquoi parce que
les gens diront la seule manière qu'on a
de fiche tous bazar par terre c'est de
voter pour eux et bien moi je voudrais
qu'on fiche tous bazar par terre avec
les valeurs de l'humanisme de la
fraternité et le refus de la logique de
guerre civile qui est celle de Madame Le
Pen j'ai le devoir de le faire pas
simplement c'est pas une une foucade de
ma part c'est le devoir politique d'un
homme de gauche d'agir de cette manière
nous avons le devoir d'exister en dehors
d'eux qui sont les fauxoyurs de la
gauche qui ont volé les mots qui ont
abîmé l'esprit public et qui sont des
gens qui prennent en otage vous avez
entendu la tout à l'heure vous me citiez
Dre vous l'avez entendu Dr dans cette
bande sonore qui traînait sur Internet
on l'a mis un peu en valeur il les
traite lui-même de manipulateurs il dit
ce sont des menteurs ils vont essayer de
faire peur aux gens pour les obliger à
voter pour eux nous ne participons plus
à cette mascarade que ça soit bien clair
vous estimez que le principe du revolver
sur la tempe demeure même après ce
référendum qui a quand même reçu encore
plus parce que pendant le référendum qui
est d'ailleurs il se contentent de plus
moi je me suis pas c'est pas un top je
me suis pas exprimé avant tellement je
trouvais ça bon voilà quand il passe un
corp billard moi je me découvre je jette
pas des pierres bon donc le cor billard
est passé et le mort a été livré à
domicile c'est le parti socialiste et
son référendum le le le Corbière c'est
le parti bah évidemment qu'est-ce que
comment voulez-vous que j'appelle un
parti qui dit à Paris qu'il a 10000
adhérents il y a 5000 personnes qui ont
été voté il a fallu 3 jours pour les
faire sortir 12 par jour et par et par
urne c'est grotesque c'est même plus une
audience de masse c'est ce vous le
comprenez ça non mais tout le monde fait
semblant pourquoi ça occupe le ça occupe
l'actualité du dimanche mais ça n'a
aucun sens politique et à la fin de
cette histoire il vient nous prendre à
parti dit ça prouve que les gens à 89 %
veulent l'Union non pas à 89 % à 100 %
ils veulent l'Union mais pas pour leur
politique à vos conditions enfin en tous
les cas vous seriez prêt vous auriez été
prêt à discuter vous l'avez dit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais sur quel point non non
non non attendez j'ai dit si la
discussion c'était ça c'estàdire on
respecte les genses on aurait pu on
aurait été embêté d'ailleurs hein parce
que nous on a aucune confiance en eux
mais bon on aurait parlé on aurait on
aurait été mais bien sûr mais là c'est
pas le cas c'est le fouet et il faut
leur obéir et ben non on n'obéira pas
donc toute union est exclu d'ici le
premier tour de quoi parlez-vous on
parle des régional mais non ça y est les
listes sont oui bien sûr mais bon donc
au premier tour il y aura des listes en
tout cas le Parti de Gauche des fois il
est pas dans la liste des fois il est
dans une liste avec les Verts d'autres
fois c'est une liste Front gauche
d'autres fois c'est une liste Front
gauche et vert par exemple comme c'est
le cas dans dans ma circonscription
langdoc Rousillon midi pyrénée bon pof
il y a une liste tout le monde est là
euh les verrs nous euh le Front de
Gauche divisé entre vous c'est vrai qui
les communistes euh communistes qui a
des alliances Var il y a des endroits en
effet où ça va pas marcher moi je le
déplore je je le regrette qu'est-ce que
je peux faire de plus je vais pas aller
moi-même m'enfoncer les clous euh pour
tenir sur la croix hein bon donc
voilàors je le déplore honnêtement je le
dis j'ai j'ai plaidé pour l'unité
partout où où j'ai pu le faire
pardon et alors au deème tour et ben on
verra ben on verra certes mais peut-être
commener déjà vous y avez déjà réfléchi
je pense non mais c'est ma réponse ma
réponse c'est on verra si d'ici au
deuxème tour c'est les injures tous les
jours euh le le doberman Dr on me sert
tous les 5 minutes en n'oubliant jamais
de me rappeler qu'il y a 10 ans il était
jeune ou il y a 20 ans et militait avec
moi il était de gauche hein si c'est ça
plus la la le la vidéo qu'ils ont mis en
circulation pour aller retrouver une
élection où j'ai été battu en 1992 parce
qu'invers Ctait oui alors je rappelle
alors cette vidéo dans laquelle on vous
voit vous étiez dans les sones c'était
une cantonale et vous aviez dénoncé
alors la division de la gauche vous avez
dit c'est immoral c'est une faute aujhui
on vous reproche de ne pas respecter l'
mais monsieur grossior il y a 30 ans
vous n'étiez pas le même homme et ben
moi non plus et bien voilà et quand
cette affaire s'est déroulé c'est un un
un élu écologiste qui s'est maintenu au
deème tour contre moi et j'ai perdu le
siège à g GAE d'ailleurs celui qui a été
élu est devenu ensuite le maire de
droite de la ville bon et les gens l'ont
gardé depuis c'est vous dire que c'est
pas une petite affaire mais monsieur
grossior ça n'intéresse personne mais
puisque j'en parle je termine c'est ce
même verre qui nous avait fait perdre
que les socialistes ont investi et fait
élire contre une camarade de mon de mon
propre parti par conséquent je n'ai pas
de leçons de moral à recevoir de mais
attendez ce que je veux dire c'est que
si les socialistes ont décider de
consacrer le temps qui leur reste à nous
insulter et à essayer de faire peur tout
le monde au Front national ils
n'obtiendront absolument rien jamais de
nous parce que personne ne me fait peur
personne une seul colle dans le crâne
une bonne fois personne ne nous fait
peur même pas une victoire du Front
national je reviens mais j'accepte que
écoutez monsieur grossur ne tournons pas
autour du pot j'en ai assez d'entendre
ce genre d'interpellation moi j'aurais
pas peur mais monsieur grossior quand
vous avez un socialiste ici vous lui
dites la chose suivante je vous je vais
lui poser la question voyons voir dans
la région Nord tous les sondages disent
que vous avez perdu et tous les sondages
disent que Madame m Le Pen va gagner
est-ce que vous les socialistes dans la
région Nord vous êtes d'accord pour vous
écarter de la tête de et est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord pour que ce soit par
exemple madame Sandrine Rousseau qui
prennent la tête d'une liste au commune
parce que dans ce cas-là nous serions
d'accord si elle laa dirigé et que vous
viendriez nous suivre non et c'est à moi
qu'on vient demander si j'ai pas peur
d'une victoire du Front national qui
l'aura provoqué dans le Nord sinon les
socialistes eux-mêmes qui n'ont même pas
le cran de défendre la position en
envoyant leur première ligne moi je suis
allé à inimumon j'étais pas obligé d'y
aller j'ai été tenir tête à
igéne n'estigé où sont passous les héros
son V tap DESS quandétais à les
Jean-Marc K et compagnie ils sont où
tout ca ils étaient forts pour venir
m'empêcher d'y arriver à inomon mais
quand il s'agit d'aller se battre contre
elle il y a plus personne et bien après
je ne supporte pas qu'on vienne me
rendre responsable de la situation ils
sont totalement responsables totalement
coupables du désastre qu'ils ont
eux-mêmes préparé et qu'ils
entretiennent chaque jour vous dites
quand même un désastre parce que quel
aura le visage de la France s'il y a on
se retrouve avec une ou de une ou deux
régions passe au Fond national quel est
votre jugement famille Le Pen mais moi
j'ai déjà dit ce que j'en pensais à la
fin des des européennes he on m'a
reproché mon émotion parce que je
trouvais qu'elle était aut vous savez
très bien ce que j'en pense je pense que
notre notre patrie sera vu d'une autre
manière dans le monde mais est-ce que ça
qui on harcè moi à moi on pose la
question pourquoi on la pose pas au on
la pose aussi au Comé
pourquoiciste on la pose à tous ou oui
oui alors on va vous poser une question
quand il vous parle d'unité pas une fois
vous leur avez dit mais l'unité de qui
avec quoi pourquoi faire non si Monsieur
Camba desliiss est d'accord pour venir
manifester avec moi contre le
gouvernement et la politique d'austérité
je vous garantis que je m'en vais
discuter avec lui d'un programme commun
mais tant qu'il reste caché dans son
bureau à inventer des histoires de fou
comme cette histoire de de de référendum
non il rest chez lui et moi histoire de
fou alors donc à corbillard vous avez
parlé d'un corbillard concernant le
parti soci oui la dernière fois j'avais
parlé d'un astromort maintenant
corbillard parce qu'il faut quand même
changer les images je dis bon quand le
corps billard pas je me découvre donc le
corps billard du référendum c'est pas
mal non qu encore une question sur
Marine Le Pen elle était à Lyon
aujourd'hui en jugement correctionnel
pour ses propos sur les prières de rue
et qu'elle avait décrite comme une
occupation elle ne retire rien elle a
prévenu en arrivant on l'écoute et vous
réagirez car on
a la réquisition du procureur ceux qui
me traînent devant le tribunal
correctionnel prennent la responsabilité
de cela voilà de la violation de la
liberté d'expression dans notre pays et
de la tentative d'empêcher une
responsable politique qui représente des
millions de Français de soulever des
sujets qui sont des sujets essentiels
pour notre liberté individuelle pour
l'autorité de l'État pour la défense de
la laïcité pour la défense de la loi
alors votre réaction sachant que donc la
relaxe a été requise par le procureur
qui estime que Marine Le Pen parlait ce
jour-là d'un certain nombre de personnes
et pas de toute la communauté musulmane
ce sont ces arguments alors il y a deux
choses à considérer il y a d'abord ce
qu'elle vient de dire CH Oui c'est
naturellement une provocatrice et une
menteuse car elle excipe de la laïcité
or les prières de rue contre lesquelles
elle a protesté sont des prières de ru
de musulmans j'ai jamais dit moi j'ai
approuvé les prières de rue je
désapprouve toutes les prières de rue et
c'est un problème de circulation et pas
de laïcité bien les prières de rue
qu'elles dénonceelles sont celles des
musulmans je fais remarquer que
intervalle très régulier il y a des
prières de rue de certain un fanatique
catholique je ne confonds pas avec le
reste de l'église catholique devant les
hôpitaux ou les endroits où se
pratiquent les interruptions volontaire
de grossesse on ne se souvient pas que
qui que ce soit a jamais protesté contre
ce type d'énergumaine et leur pratique
extrêmement offensante et violatrice de
la liberté individuelle des femmes qui
ont déjà à aller jusque là dans leur
propre parcours cette liberté là n'a pas
l'air de gêner Madame Le Pen par contre
la liberté de circulation dans telle ou
telle rue oui ça lui importe donc c'est
une menteuse uniquement préoccupée par
un état d'esprit de guerre civile
antimusulman voilà et quand on dit que
on dénonce certains et pas tout le monde
et bien on le fait dans des conditions
respectueuse moi je dénonce les prières
de rue devant les centres d'interruption
volontaire de grossesse mais je proclame
que je ne confonds pas c'est quelques
énergumenes avec les croyants
catholiques de mon pays qui sont tous
bons républicains et respectueux de la
liberté des autres maintenant deuxème
point rel la relaxe alors c'est le
moment de vous dire quelque chose de
très important il y a une drôle
d'ambiance judiciaire autour de Madame
Le Pen
Madame Le Pen Doren avant dit et fait ce
qu'elle veut je vous en donne un autre
exemple le code électoral et le code
pénal punissent très durement ceux qui
quand ils sont candidats dans une
élection font semblant d'être de s s
destractes en faisant s bloc soit ceux
des autres exemple je parti de gauche
ferai un tract socialiste ou bien un
tract UMP évidemment racontant dedans
des choses qui soulèvent le dégoût des
gens et bien c'est ce qu'elle a fait
avec moi elle l'a dit à la télévision
donc il y a pas de de doute sur le fait
qu'elle assumait la responsabilité elle
a été après d'innombrables procédures de
retardement condamnée au maximum en
première instance au maximum de l'amende
il restait plus qu'un point
l'inéligibilité
elle fait appel et en appel relaxe que
ce passe-t-il dans ce pays elle assume
un délit à la télévision et elle est
relaxée elle rentre dans un tribunal et
elle dit je maintiens tout ce que j'ai
dit et le procureur demande la relaxe
qui est le procureur dans le casre mon
affaire il a dit qu'il s'en mêlait pas
l'enquête était perdue il n'avait pas
lui-même poursuivi alors qu'est-ce que
vous voulez dire vous mettez qui en
cause je mets en cause le fait que le
parquet dépend directement du garde des
saau et le garde des saau aurait dû
donner des instructions générales
concernant les élections concernant la
tenue du débat public notamment
concernant les élections des
instructions générales je ne dis pas
particulières car à l'issue des
élections 2012 il y a eu beaucoup de
questions de poser je vous rappelle que
là dans la circonscription d'baumon on a
trouvé 18 fauxes sign
qui ont été reconnu comme t ce qui
prouve à l'évidence un complot donné
raison la semaine dernière encore contre
Marine Le Pen donc on peut pas dire que
systématiquement non mais c'était autre
chose elle la protège ni que Madame
tobir madame tobira pourrait donner des
instruction qui permettrait par exemple
d'apurer d'une certaine manière
l'atmosphère et le niveau de ce qui se
dit dans ce pays mais en tout cas en
matière d'élection elle ne l'a jamais
fait ça fera donc la deuxème fois que le
parquet qui dépend directement du G de
Dessau propose la relaxe à propos de
Madame le vous dire qu'elle est ménagé
politiquement absolument j'affirme que
Madame Le Pen est instrumentalisé par le
système UMP d'un côté où je sais pas
comment il s'appelle maintenant
frauduleusement les républicains alors
que nous sommes tous et d'autre part par
le PS parce que c'est son principal et
unique et exclusif argument de vente
s'il n'y a plus de Madame Le Pen il y a
aucune raison de voter PS vous parlez de
François Hollande mais enfin François
Hollande nomme les parquettistes non
serreur est-ce qu'il n'a pas le pouvoir
de les nommer c'est une accusation très
grave qui vise en plus le chef de l'État
qui se présente comme le rempart du
attendez rajoutez pas pour faire du du
buz monsieur monsieur gross une
accusation très grave on fait de la
politique on explique ce qui se passe
bon oui ou non les parquets dépendent-il
du garde des saau monsieur grossior vous
avez fait des études de droit je le sais
oui ils en dépendent n'est-ce pas oui
donc est-ce qu'un procureur qui a une
affaire pareille dit ah bah tiens parce
dans ce pays les procureurs heureusement
ne sont pas indépendants ce sont les
avocat vous avez dit tout à l'heure il y
a un menteur à l'Élysée il y a quelqu'un
qui tire des ficelles aussi quand on
vouscout mais écoutez personne ne peut
croire que ça profit F bien sûr est-ce
que vous croyez qu'un parqueettiste
c'est quand même quelqu'un de sérieux un
juge comme ça tout seul ne prend aucun
conseil aucun avis et décide qu'il y a
relaxe relaxe pour Madame Le Pen à Doué
relaxe pour Madame Le Pen à lon dans
deux cas où elle risque l'inéligibilité
parce que dans les affaires où elle
risque pas l'inéligibilité là elle peut
être condamnée le gouvernement étant
socialiste le chef de l'État étant
socialiste vous dites en gros que
François Hollande euh veut garder Marine
Le Pen comme comme comme candidate
adversaire dans la perspective de la
présidentielle de 2017 mais madame
m'exprimez si mal en français qu'il y
ait besoin de répéter ce que je dis sous
une forme caricaturale est-ce que est-ce
que je parle mal le français compris
mais mais bon comme c'est la force de
votre accusation parce que lui-même Fran
nousite à vous vous faire répéter deux
mots mais on va s'arrêter là puisqueon a
compris ce que vous avez je je ne crois
pas la force de mon accusation elle
tient à des faits et il est extravagant
que vous ne reteniez de cela que
l'accusation vous ne retenez pas les
faits oui ou non la relaxe par des
parquettistes à deux reprises sur des
cas où elle risque l'inéligibilité est
quelque chose qui a une conséquence
politique majeure oui ou non oui par la
force des choses donc on a écouté votre
démonstration et votre accusation merci
merci Luc pine Tarn arrive maintenant
Jean-Luc Mélanchon pour la trème partie
de preu par 3 avec cette question parmi
d'autres d'ailleurs relevant de la
politique internationale européenne à
propos de la Syrie est-ce que vous
faites confiance à Vladimir Poutine le
ciel de Syrie depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant est donc partagé par les
avions de la coalition mené par les
États-Unis avec la présence française
bien sûr et de l'Alliance sy
russo-syrienne avec des objectifs
militaires et diplomatiques qui poussent
à la division on écoute François
Hollande notamment sur le sort du
président syrien et son jeu
l'intervention russe de ce point de vue
euh peut
consolider le régime mais ne sauvera pas
Bachard il est très clairement dit que
bacharassan ne peut pas être l'avenir ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que il
partira c'est ça que ça veut dire et on
est tous de ce point de vue d'accord
alors certains pourrai dire partir tout
de suite partir au milieu partir à la
fin ce qui est important c'est de dire
qu'il n'est pas l'avenir et donc à
partir de là il faut aller le plus vite
possible vers cette transition
politique par donc nous a rejoint avec
cette question sur la Syrie oui bonsoir
Michel bonsoir jeanluc Mélenchon al
estce que vous faites pour reprendre la
question de de Michel grossur est-ce que
vous faites confiance à Vladimir Poutine
pour nous débarrasser du groupe état
islamique de qui doiton se débarrasser
s'il vous plaît du groupe état islamique
en Syrie est-ce que oui non parce que
suivant les moments les minutes et les
heures les Alliés changeants pas très
bien on a changé de terrain d'accord non
non mais je sais je parle très bien je
sais de quoi vous parlez vous inquiétez
pas he voilà donc mais quand on parle de
la Syrie je fais remarquer je commence
par vous faire remarquer que Al-Qaïda
est l'allié des alliés parce que paraîil
c'est comme ça qu'on les appelle de
François Hollande de Monsieur Obama et
de quelques autres n'est-ce pas Al-Qaïda
est allié sous le nom alnostra mais les
mêmes nous les bombardons en Afghanistan
parce que ils sont méchants en
Afghanistan ils sont méchants et en
Syrie ils sont gentils alors daesh est
méchant en Syrie mais redevient gentil
quand il s'attaque au Kurdes vous savez
c'est un mééoù on se moque des gens hein
que se passe-t-il là-bas toutes les
grandes puissances ont les doigts dedans
et les principaux financeurs de la
région c'est-à-dire Qatar Arabie
Saoudite Turquie qui sont les grandes
puissances du coin la grande puissance
et Iran et c'est une guerre tout ce qu'
a de plus classique et conventionnelle
d'influence pour détruire des pays qui
posent de manière séculaire des
problèmes aux monarchies du golf et aux
turc et aux Iraniens pour des raisons
que nous allons épargner à ce plateau à
cet instant donc de quoi me parlez-vous
et que me demandez-vous au juste qui a
la meilleure stratégie en en Syrie
est-ce que ce sont les alliés la France
AC les États-Unis par exemple ou alors
Vladimir Poutine qui a décidé
d'intervenir de son côté notamment au
sol en Syrie voilà alors clairement la
stratégie américaine et française est en
flop total parce que daesh qu'on devait
contenir à un endroit se retrouve à
l'autre je vous signale que la dernière
fois qu'on les combattait c'était en
Irak on les retrouve là donc c'est un
échec total et on est censé les avoir
frappé je ne sais combien de fois en
Irak c'est curieux ces gens résistent
aux bombes avec une vigueur inouie
d'accord bon lesevel en Syrie maintenant
que l'Evel arrivé en Syrie on on
recommence la même comédie tout ça n
débouché sur rien les Russes sont
arrivés et que voit-on à peine arri-t-il
se donnant pour objectif de frapper
daesh y parvenant avec un certain succès
queils se font reprocher de bombarder
les opposants et la population civile
les opposants c'est notamment ce que dit
aujourd'hui une ONG hein qui sur le N si
c'est une ONG doit-on la croire pour
autant mais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas en
effet vous avez raison alors pourquoi
pas me croire moi bon j'ai au moins
d'aussi bonnes informations croyez-moi
que doit-on dire il bombarde des popul
civile est-ce vrai ou pas bah oui vous
connaissez une guerre où on bombarde et
où les civils ne reçoivent pas de bombes
ça n'existe pas la preuve les les
bienfaisants intervenant en au Yémen qui
eux vous le savez ne font que du bien
aux 40000 personnes qu'ils ont tué et
bien eux ils bombardent des nos quand on
est en Afghanistan bombarde des hôpitaux
mais là non comme c'est les gentils on n
parle pas on va parler de ceux qui
éventu que vous contestez la Russie
bombarderait surtout des rebelles cela
même qu'on célébré hein quand il y a 4
ans ils se sont levés contre jamais
célébré donc je ne comprends pas pourqui
cyez pas l'opposition modérée mais ça
n'a pas de sens des islamistes modérés
vous avez vu ça où vous ou ça existe à
part dans vos canards ça existe pas sur
le terrain c'est sauvage comme les aut
dans la bouche de nombreux dirigeants
occidentaux ça existe oui oui oui ça
existe puivant les mois ça change je
viens de vous dire à l'instant que les
modérés c'est Al-Qaïda il y a même pas
de mois on les traité de terroristes et
on les bombarde en Afghanistan on se
moque du monde donc pour être clair
Vladimir Vladimir Poutine a la bonne
stratégie en frappant indistinctement
peut-êre plus d'ailleurs al noosra
que is vous ne savez pas ce qui se passe
vous savez ce qu'on dit dans dans le
métier de journaliste que quand il y a
une guerre la première victime c'est la
vérité c'est une guerre donc vous ne
savez pas ce qui se passe ce qui est
absurde c'est le comportement d'un
certain nombre de gens qui se sont pris
les pieds dans le tapis je voudrais
rappeler une chose tout à l'heure le
président François Hollande parlait de
Bachar Bachar c'est son prénom son nom
c'est Monsieur elAssad c'est à peu près
comme si Bachar alAssad disait François
a tort hein bon et bien il dit il faut
faire partir monsieur l'ASSAD vous avez
entendu comme moi oui vous n'êtes pas
d'accord est-ce que la solution passe
parassad je vous signale que les Russes
ont signé un accord déjà en 2012 dans
lequel tout le monde était d'accord pour
qu'il y ait une transition démocratique
avec un gouvernement d'union nationale
pourquoi n'y en a-t-il pas eu parce qu'à
ce moment-là les Français et les
Américains ont décidé que cet accord ne
leur convenait pas donc il n'est pas
vrai maintenant quand François Hollande
dit il partira au début au milieu ou à
la fin peu importe mais il partira il a
fait exactement le contraire et rendu
impossible cette solu
la solution qu'il évoque c'est celle que
les Russes ont mis au point cet été avec
une série de pays qu'ils ont rencontré
et je vous signale que quand vous dites
les Alliés vous parlez d'occidentaux qui
sont très éloignés du théâtre des
opérations et que sur place autour des
Russes vous avez des gens qui eux sont
présents localement c'est-à-dire une
série de pays dans le secteur donc
admettez qu'il y a là une situation
assez embrouillée pour qu'on s'évite
pourquoi j'en parle comme ça après tout
je pourrais très bien dire c'est pas mon
affaire c'est que il y a un risque
d'embrasement absolument terrifiant il y
a un risque de guerre mondiale dans
cette affaire quand j'entends les
Anglais dire qu'ils prétendent bombarder
les avions russes qui violeraient
l'espace ou je sais pas trop quoi ce
sont des fous de faire ça il ne faut pas
faire ça il faut maintenant s'assoir à
la table discuter et on discute avec les
genscass avec mais écoutez c'est pas ça
la question que vous devable du massacre
de son peuple je le
dis nous et nous tous nous allons le
répéter encore avec les gens qui sont à
la
technique la question que vous devriez
me poser c'est est-ce que on négocie
avec DAEs a pas l'air de vous déranger
je vient de dire on négocie avec ceux
qui combattent la première idée qui vous
vient à l'esprit c'est Bachar alAssad
c'est-à-dire que daesh n'est pas
l'ennemi pour vous pour vous tous
l'ennemi essentiel vous ne savez même
plus pourquoi c'est Bachar alAssad et
vous voulez vous pensez que l'objectif
prioritaire c'est de le faire tomber à
n'importe quel et ben moi je ne suis pas
d'accord pour qu'il tombe à n'importe
quel prix je suis pour qu'il s'en aille
et pour qu'il a un gouvernement d'union
nationale mais il s'en ira quand les
circonstances seront réunies pour que ce
soit un accord honnête sinon vous aurez
la Libye B c'est ça que vous voulez on a
compris ou compris question sur la
France exactement sur la stratégie de la
France en Syrie qui a décidé de frapper
des cibles prioritaire notamment des
camps d'entraitement où se trouvent des
Français partis là-bas faire le djihad
est-ce que vous êtes pour ces
éliminations ciblées au nom de la
légitime défense euh l'argument de la
légitime défense n'est n'est pas fondé
c'est un argument de grande puissance
moi j'évite toujours de de critiquer
l'action de de de nos armées une fois
qu'on est engagé je dis avant ce que je
pense je pense erreur je l'ai dit au
début hein bon maintenant euh ils font
leur travail Vous dites-v vous qu'il
bombardent des camps d'entraînement et
en plus vous avez appris qu'il y avait
des Français dedans donc je vous
félicite pour la qualité de vos
informations moi je ne sais rien de tout
ça je sais que l'aviation française
frappe un certain nombre de cibes je
suis sûr que les militaires les ont bien
choisis mais tout ça la la solution dans
ce genre de situation est rarement
militaire tout le monde le sait si la
situation était militaire nous devrions
connaître la paix le bonheur et la joie
en Libye ainsi qu'en Irak ainsi qu'en
Afghanistan et là-bas partout nous avons
défendu des grandes causes très
intéressantes très intelligentes le
résultat au prix d'un chaos
indescriptible de souffrance
épouvantable et de flot d'immigrés dont
vous savez tous que ces pauvres gens
fuitient quelque chose que plus personne
ne cont on parle justement d'autant que
le flux s'accélère ces dernières an
voilà alors Angela Merkel et toute
l'Europe fait aujourd'hui les yeux doux
à la Turquie justement pour indendiguer
ce flot de réfugiés c'est une honte
est-ce qu'il faut ouvrir selon vous
grand la porte de l'Union européenne à
la Turquie non de toute façon ça c'est
une ça n'a pas de sens il y a des
procédure pour entrer dans l'Union
européenne il y en a au moins au minimum
si ça marchait bien pour au moins encore
5 ou 6 ans mais est-ce qu'il faut
accélérer peut-être au nom d'un accord
avec la Turquie VO ce qui attendez il y
a deux questions qu'est-ce qu'on est en
train de faire avec la Turquie encore
une fois de la politique à courte vue
comme on déclenche des flux de de de de
migration il y a pas quelqu'un qui veut
les arrêter avant qu'ils arrivent chez
nous donc on est prêt à n'importe quoi
donc on va soutenir le régime turc qui
lui au lieu de combattre daesh bombarde
les Kurdes qui eux combattent daesh vous
vous en souvenez de ça la Turquie est
membre de l'OTAN on croyait que les les
membres de l'OTAN étaient alliés pour
faire la guerre en Syrie à daesh non la
Turquie fait la guerre aux Kurdes qui
font la guerre à daesh faut quand même
rappeler ces choses-là deuxièmement la
Turquie le gouvernement turc actuel
pratique une politique extrêmement
agressive contre la démocratie et les
partis de liberté en Turquie et c'est
ces gens-là qu'on va les sououtenir donc
le voyageang la Merkel ce weekend à
Istanbul c'était de la précipitation
alors euh je pense qu'elle est en train
de s'affoler je pense que elle se elle
se sent en rôle euh de de de comment
dire de d'un leadership en Europe que
personne ne lui a demandé de faire B
pourquoi c'est elle qui va au nom de
quoi qui l'
mandatéage bon ben par la force des
choses monsieur Holland toujours
d'accord avec elle mais c'est pas le
sujet le plus important c'est un sujet
important je je vous le concède mais
regardez comment Atel pu c'est pas ça le
plus grave le plus honteux le plus
immoral c'est qu'elle est osé dire au
Grecs on est capable de réviser votre
politique d'austérité si vous vous
gardez les pauvres gens qui arrivent
c'est c'est est-ce que je crois que
personne s'est rendu compte réellement
de cette offre grossière et c'est ce
gouvernement allemand est le champion du
monde de la grossièreté de la brutalité
il y a même un vice-ministre des finance
qui a dit ah mais si les Grecs
retiennent pas les les migrants on leur
donnera même pas l'aide qui est prévu
vous dites ça d'Angel Merkel qui a
ouvert tout grande les les les
frontières de l'Allemagne au réfugiés
c'est un fait benah écoutez si vous êtes
content tout va bien non je je rappelle
mais mais ça tient pas de bout ce que
vous dites ce n'est pas vrai monsieur
grossur elle a pas été quand même parmi
les pays européens celle qui a le plus
et le mieux peut-être acc ou lu reproche
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs à droite parmi
attendez vous êtes incroyable quoi c'est
mais la communication c'est pas la
réalité Madame Merkel a dit qu'elle
était prête à recevoir 800000 personnes
aussitôt vous avez tous dit ah Madame
Merkel c'est formidable le point qui le
journal grotesque est même amusé à dire
et si seulement elle était française
peut-être qu'ils ont perdu le bon sens
ça peut vouloir dire qu'un chancelier
allemand soit français c'est très
intéressant comme idée enfin bref comme
dans ce pays tout au ha de but on est
prêt à admirer n'importe qui pour
n'importe quoi on a trouvé ça génial et
moi j'ai immédiatement dit ah bon et
l'année prochaine encore 800000 et
d'après encore 800000 personne n'est
capable de faire ça pas plus Madame
Merkel quelqu'un d'autre qui avait
raison moi 3 jours après elle ferme la
frontière dites voir vous venez de me
dire à l'instant qu'elle a ouvert les
bras aux immigrés vous avez entendu dire
qu'elle a fermé la frontière ou pas
c'est arrivé jusque dans ce studio vous
le savez donc arrêtez de dire qu'elle a
ouvert les bras la terre entière ce
n'est pas vrai elle a pendant 2 jours
tenu un propos complètement opportuniste
en se disant venez par ici les migrants
bien formés parce que nous en avons
besoin pour la main d'œuvre en Allemagne
et comme tout le monde a dit mais c'est
pas possible on narrivera jamais à tenir
le coup parce qu'il en arrive des
milliers et des milliers au lieu de
s'occuper d'interrompre la cause du
départ des gens on en est encore empêché
de vouloir les empêcher d'arriver en
faisant quoi en restant chez les Turcs
ou en restant chez les les réfugiés sur
les réfugiés en France qu'on a une
situation qui est très difficile c'est à
calé en quelques semaines on est passé
de 3000 à 6000 réfugiés on a découvert
hier que la jungle de Calais se situé en
zone co qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
évacue non non bien sûr que non on en
accueille encore d'autres non qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez c'est ce qui se passe
bah c'est ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire non ils continuent à bombarder à
passer les accords qui font partir les
gens de chez eux c'est qui les gens qui
sont là vous pourriez vous demander
c'est pas des réfugiés c'est pas des
nombres ils ont ils ont des n ils
viennent de quelque part ils viennent
d'où à votre ils viennent de plusieurs
pays non ils viennent d'Afghanistan mais
si vous voulez le voir aller voir sur le
bord canal à
parore tous des pays en guerre qui fait
les guerres qui c'est passes pauvres
mais demain demain Bernard casenuve le
ministre de l'Intérieur est sur place à
calé il serend à nouveau à calé attendez
quoi ou et ben c'est la même problème
que vous me diriez il y a un gars qui a
perdu une jambe et il a mis une jambe de
bois et la jambe de bois va pas bien on
met un cataplasme c'est cataplasme sur
des jambes de bois nous n'avons que des
mauvaises solutions maintenant vous
comprenez c'est ça la nouveauté de la
situation pardon de vous répondre comme
ça mais c'est inextricable on continue à
augmenter les raisons de partir et
ensuite on va empêcher les gens
d'arriver et ensuite chacun s'arrange
pour faire en sorte que les réfugiés
restent chez le voisin donc pratiquement
cette situation devient insoluble où
veulent aller ces gens ils veulent aller
en Angleterre qu'ils y aillent ah oui on
ouvre bah pourquoi pas pu que c'est là
qu'ils veulent aller quelle la raison de
les retenir chez nous alors qu'il
veulent aller ailleurs dernière question
sur les déboutés très important ce que
je suis en train de vous dire je suis
pour qu'on permette à ces gens de passer
en Angleterre voilà puisqu'ils veulent
aller en Angleterre ils passent en
Angleterre dans le même temps
effectivement il y a le rapport de la
Cour des comptes aujourd'hui qui dit que
96 % des déboutés du droit d'asile en
France ne partent il faudrait y remédier
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de
répondre à la Cour des comptes mais et
que ça nous coûte trop cher ah oui bien
sûr bon alors c'est plusieurs questions
dans
une les déboutés du droit d'asile ne
s'en vont pas tu parles d'une découverte
et on paye des gens pour trouver ça ils
avent qu'à poser la question n'importe
quel élu lui-même bon évidemment la
misère engendrera toujours la migration
les gens ne partent pas par plaisir je
voudrais vous le rappeler je voudrais
vous rappeler que ce sont des êtres
humains arrêtez de considérer ça comme
comme un fléo comprenez que ce sont des
êtres humains bien sûr qu'on ne peut pas
tout faire bien sûr qu'on n' pas la
capacité d'absorber la population de
tous ces pays mais un peu d'humilité
quand même les Libanais accueillent des
quantités considérables de réfugiés tout
le monde accueille des quantités
considérables de réfugiés et nous les
pays les plus riches nous sommes là à
nous discuter sur la meilleure manière
de les laisser crever on est d'accord
avec vous sur le devoir et le besoin de
d'humanité merci parci à vous voyez dans
une émission j'arrive même à vous tirer
quelques bons sentiments mais je
l'avais ce sens deavais avant même allez
à très vite bientôt l'avait
[Musique]
avant